it's Thursday October 23rd and you're
watching Gamespot news Chris Waters here
to relay to you what's been relayed to
me by an elite Cadre of international
Gamespot nosologists through a system of
coded ciphers and vacuum tubes it's all
very complicated and abstruse and would
take days to explain so suffice to say
there's some news and I'm going to tell
it to
you we'll start with a couple of Xbox
One related stories that mainly focus on
stuff the Xbox one doesn't really do yet
but will do in the future Phil Spencer
has acknowledged that Xbox One install
times are not as fast as they want them
to be and in some cases significantly
worse than those of the PlayStation 4 he
speculated that it may have stemmed from
Microsoft move away from requiring an
always on interet connection but said
that he didn't want to make any excuses
and that speeding things up was high on
his priority list it won't be until 2015
that the Xbox one gets a screenshot
feature why Phil Spencer told IGN that
it was a little more technically
challenging than they first first
imagined and even the patched in photo
mode in Shadows of Mordor is a
significantly limited version of the
proper feature look at this
Photograph every time I do it makes me
laugh and finally the free version of
Xbox music is going away and the
precisely nobody that I know who uses
Xbox music will have to pay a
subscription fee for the service
starting in December remember earlier in
the week when an indie developer tweeted
death threats at gave new over steam's
promotion of his game yeah that guy left
the studio and the remaining team is
super sorry in a statement on their
website developer code avaris said that
they won't be changing their game or
Studio name in an effort to distance
themselves from this Fiasco they thanked
those who still support their game
paranautical activity and said hopefully
valve and Gabe will accept our apology
this is not a ruse to get back on the
platform this is a serious apology for
poor behavior and speaking of apologies
EA has added some incentives for you to
buy NBA Live 15 during launch week while
acknowledging that the series has had
some issues that might not make that so
appealing referencing the 3 we delay in
a blog post the developers write that we
know that NBA Live has been on let's
call it a journey the offer on the table
is for $30 worth of bonus content for
the game's ultimate te mode when you buy
NBA Live 15 during launch week and
that's really all for today newswise
around here we're about 30 hours deep in
our extra life charity live stream in
which folks from around the globe are
playing 100 games in 100 hour hours to
benefit Children's Hospitals stop by at
gamespot.com chat chat with us for a bit
and consider donating for the
children